you know what rabbits they're supposed
to be cute on paper they're adorable
lovable animals have you ever gotten
close to a rabbit that thing no let me
tell you I don't understand this fear I
think it's cute
rabbits that you can tell in their eyes
they have the brain of like a sociopath
if you put a rabbit brain in a human
body you have Michael Myers the killer
there no empathy I'm afraid of
butterflies so I guess we all have
something you can never really tell
where they're gonna lam they look cute
but when you look closely they're like
monsters really
if you go in expecting get out you will
be very surprised it's so out of the box
and it's so controversial I think that
people are really gonna love it my MO is
always whatever people are expecting try
to give them something more something
different our originals are five million
dollars it's a much bigger movie but it
was exhilarating to see him take off on
the way that he did I think they'll love
how different it is from modern-day
horror movies I don't know if it's
darker than get out or it's more
psychologically unsettling and harrowing
and he has a signature that you start to
experience watching his second movie so
I think they'll be surprised and
delighted by the things that are recalls
but also the things that are complete
the project they won't stop until they
kill us
this movie is not get out - and you'll
have to see why and now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]